pues el propio don otro ha reaccionado
según fuentes cercanas al expresidente
de forma positiva a la defensa que
hicieron sus abogados hoy acá en el
capitolio se vio pues mucho más positivo
a comparación de lo que del trabajo que
hicieron sus abogados el martes donde
fueron bastante cuestionados los
abogados de donald trump
básicamente compartieron los siguientes
argumentos que las palabras del ex
presidente no tenían nada que ver con
los hechos de violencia el 6 de enero y
que lo que estaban argumentando los
demócratas es simplemente
inconstitucional en este momento se está
llevando a cabo entonces las 4 horas de
preguntas que tienen los senadores
republicanos y demócratas para hacerle
tanto a los fiscales que acusan de
insurrección al presidente al ex
presidente don otros como la defensa de
el ex presidente se está argumentando
sobre todo porque del otro no hizo nada
cuando sabía que su vicepresidente
estaba en peligro y de hecho estaban
buscando al vicepresidente para
como tenían planeado los simpatizantes y
las milicias de simpatizantes a donald
trump el 6 de enero porque no hizo nada
y cuando se enteró de lo que estaba
pasando en el capitolio son preguntas
que la defensa de la nación sin embargo
no ha podido responder avanza entonces
ya dos horas y media de preguntas y
tienen como máximo cuatro horas para
formular preguntas y responderlas
cristóbal muy brevemente que sigue ahora
y se espera que el presidente el ex
presidente donante sea hallado culpable
si ahora sigue entonces los dos lados se
han dicho que no van a citar testigos
eso quiere decir que mañana alrededor de
las 10 de la mañana como lo han dicho
varias fuentes se va a resumir el juicio
político con comentarios finales
argumentos finales para que alrededor de
las 3 de la tarde hora de washington ya
se vote recordemos que se necesitan dos
tercios para hallar a trump culpable y
su reacción y lo que dicen analistas y
lo que dicen los pronósticos es que va a
ser muy difícil que los demócratas
logren estos dos tercios es decir trump
sería absuelto de su segundo juicio
político